[Musik]
es war echte leben in der schweiz in den
sand reduzieren
alles gemacht fasst musik spielt darin
auch abwaschen servieren pizza machen
national haareschneiden personal fast
alles klar
[Musik]
es war schöne zeit und ich wünschte das
habe ich mit den abwaschen angefangen
von ganz 100
es ist nach oben kein party
das ist auch erste laden
[Musik]
mit dieser filiale im zürcher kreis 5
legte campus saale vor rund 20 jahren
den grundstein für sein imperium von
günstig bis salons
zehn geschwistern helfen und familie
mutter alleine also allein stehende
mutter und kinder das war erst die erste
ziel das nicht gestoppt nichts meinen
gedanken machen
[Musik]
eingeladen grüezi diese dreharbeiten
fanden noch vor der krise statt zu
diesem zeitpunkt wenn der tram kings
alice unternehmen von 14 für salons und
zwei restaurants
so hast du keine rampensau ist umtriebig
und beharrlich eigenschaften die für
eine tellerwäscher karriere hilfreich
sind gut 20 jährige flüchtete kurde
allein aus syrien in die schweiz
drei jahre später eröffnete er dieses
geschäft bewegung in der schweiz das war
alles nicht einfach aber das ist alles
möglich wenn man will und ein mann dran
arbeiten
das kann man das vielen lesern wünsche
sein antrieb in der schwierigen
anfangszeit irgendwann die familie zu
sich in die schweiz zu holen
[Musik]
freunde fand er hier schnell einer ist
andreas schlegel sein erster kunde
[Musik]
müsste rein gekommen naja ist klar aber
ich habe gesehen dass mozart sein ist
nachricht davon aber kommt machen wir
gehen durch den ungefähr schon lange war
das begründet also mitschnitt ja das ist
wahr das bringt glück der erste kunde
auf dem rad geschichte und das hat sich
über jahre vertieft denn irgendwann
nicht gemacht also seine freundschaften
verschaffen haben uns alle ein potentes
netzwerk unerlässlich für einen
erfolgreichen multi unternehmer das land
island praktisch findet in syrien gehört
die krankenzahl ii zur unterdrückten
kurdischen minderheit
nach dem motto da und musikschule es
gibt nicht der andere weg aus der mitte
nächste schritt musste ich ministerien
sein muss dann wenn ich weg militär von
diktatoren machen
er sah keine möglichkeit in syrien seine
lebensträume zu verwirklichen
du musst in bars partei seien vitamin b
dass die kasse film studieren in diesem
moment wo du kannst nicht mit eine
eigene muttersprache hellen der schule
gehen und kann es doch nicht die schule
studieren was du kannst durch den denen
du bist auch qualifiziert um das
studieren also nicht nur nicht
nachvollziehen und du darfst nicht
studieren weil du bist nicht in diesem
partei wo im inland ist also was machst
du da also wenn du hast möglichkeit den
traum vom film studium wollte er in der
schweiz nach gleichzeitig eröffnete er
dieses restaurant und dort ist ein
coiffure imperium aus zur filiale im
multikulturellen zürcher kreis 5 kamen
im laufe der zeit geschäfte in der
teuren innenstadt dazu
das wichtigste die großfamilie ist
mittlerweile wieder vereint fast alle
geschwister leben in der schweiz und
arbeiten im unternehmen
die jüngste bruder führt diese filiale
[Musik]
mit regisseur paul riniker verbindet
rammt ihm sali die leidenschaft zum
filmemachen
[Musik]
100 prozentig also den familien sind
viele geschäfte aber auch eine schwäche
das direkt endet die wände mir genau in
den letzten jahren vergrößert im saal
ist ein unternehmen sukzessive für jeden
bruder ein neues geschäft und mut und er
schadet ganze familie nicht lassen wir
ihm machen gäbe würde im chance zum
einfach probiert und dann wird haben die
chance gegeben
ich glaube er hat recht es gut die
berühmte wirklich macht alles
selbstständig und die bald sie werden
auch mithelfen dass ich nur filmemacher
einmal
und das wäre super dass seine wäre eine
kleine belohnung und vor den brüdern
nicht mehr erweitern und sitzen nur
filme machen das wäre auch eine option
zu bauen
[Applaus]
mit einem eigenen film projekt
beschäftigt sich hand gegen salih seit
zwei jahren das haus seines freundes
andreas schlegel soll im roadmovie eine
asylunterkunft darstellen
also die haus ist genau was ist meine
vorstellung des support alte schweizer
traditionshaus sehr schweizer zu einer
attraktion haus habe ich immer mit
vorgestellt wo ich bin neu in der
schweiz gekommen ich habe auch so in
einer art gewohnt ein projekt das ist
der hauseingang des haupteingangs amrani
auch den kopf dahinter
das wären 3 perfekt geplant hier ist die
schlussszene des films geplant
es ist die geschichte eines kurden der
in die schweiz reist und seinen sohn
zurück nach syrien zu holen
durch diesen protagonisten angesetzt so
schwierigen die immigranten wo in der
schweiz oder ganz europa leben
es ist nicht einfach viele wo sie haben
ihnen heimat verlassen
also nicht freiwillig aber viele haben
auch freiwillig sie wollten noch bessere
leben haben und die von den rote bessere
leben haben sie sollen schauen wie ist
es nicht einfach wenn du deinen land
verlassen und du um andere ort genau
wenn du einen baum von ihren wurzeln in
anderen pflanzen das wäre nie wie vorher
kommen während seiner anfangszeit in der
schweiz vermisst krampitz saale die
familie schmerzlich aus dieser
persönlichen erfahrung wieder andere
syrer von einer überstürzten flucht nach
europa abhalten
mir selber ist wirklich fällt emotional
ist nicht viel weil sind okay jetzt ganz
familie sind da das muss man auch sagen
du hast deine heimat jahren hierher
gebracht
der unternehmer fühlt sich auch dank
freunden wie andreas schlegel in der
schweiz zu hause
dieser unterstützt ihn bis heute bei
sprachlichen belangen zb der deutschen
untertitelung des films
[Musik]
rankin sully beabsichtigt das roadmovie
in einem alternativen zürcher kino
vorzuführen
die szenen in syrien wurden bereits
gedreht mit einer schweizer film crew
reiste er extra in sein geburtsland alle
karten darauf gelassen dass ich lesung
für ihn fertigmachen
ich hoffe schaffen wir das aber mit
einer karte per e mail
die nationalrätliche energie finanzieren
[Musik]
auch auf geschäftsebene a tramp saale
appetit auf mehr
im zürcherischen dietikon ist die erste
salleck um die tor eingeplant mit seinem
architekten klärt der unternehmer die
letzten details für den umbau fasst
warten wir ein jahren wissen da jetzt
langsam der hoffnung claude nobs geld
würden das war eine bewilligung und es
geht
seit jahren wächst das saale unternehmen
obwohl der gründer stets betont dass er
am liebsten nur filme machen würde
was treibt ihn an freude am geld das sie
möchte finanzielle vogel ich werde in
jedem fall nicht
also das war nie ziel also mein leben
war nie ziel einfach freude wenn ich
sehr andere abend freude und haben
arbeit und kann ich kommen gratis essen
da mein freude einladen
er fragt wenn ich einen film machen noch
ich lade leute da das ist unsere über
karl immer der uns hier nicht mal immer
uns weh und dann ist dann bin ich selbst
stolz auf rock macht geld der nicht
hauptsache nicht auf rote zahlen
dann ist gut
bruder michael ist bereits für das
benachbarte quartal geschäft
verantwortlich er wird auch
selbstständig die konditorei führen bei
wichtigen entscheidungen ist jedoch am
chiemsee tonangebend dass ihr kommen und
alle stehen als haben wir das nicht
gelernt
es gibt schon respekt vielleicht
manchmal gesagt auch nicht diesen
respekt gerade aber es geht aber schon
mehrere sind freunde einfach für seine
jüngeren brüder ist der chef freund und
auch ein bisschen vaterfigur ist es aber
verantwortliche große wo sie hat mit
einer großen familie wo sie unterstützen
ja das ist grosse belastung wirklich das
ist große verhandlung als starke rücken
kann nur helfen helfen und geben und
dann kommt alleine mehr weil es schwer
ist
im zürcher vor ort schlieren lebt ram
geniale mit seiner frau und den beiden
töchtern
hallo julia
im test muss man zusammen haase machen
ja es ist ein dreisprachige haushalt
denn katar china saale stammt
ursprünglich aus polen zum abendessen
hat die familie besuch von einem
nachbars mädchen das ehepaar lernte sich
vor bald 20 jahren kennen als die
gebürtige polin in der schweiz eine
freundin besucht
kennenlernen ist etwas sehr wichtig denn
er hat gesagt ich habe eine schöne augen
und dann ich habe gesagt ich weiß bei
den saal es herrscht eine traditionelle
rollenverteilung die ehefrau des
unternehmers kümmert sich um haus und
familie super sie so mischt sich nicht
viel unterstützung es hinten mit aller
kraft der musik an
und das ist sehr wichtig dass du hast
kein druck sie hält ihrem mann den
rücken frei kocht kurdisch und spricht
sogar seine muttersprache zu viel auf
einmal alles sprechen andere sprache ich
habe mir gefehlt alleine aber jetzt
[Musik]
macht mal
dieser habe stimmen die sagen
ja
[Musik]
naja du hast du hast du beide hände und
dann rein aber vielleicht nimmst du tuch
oder
im mai treffen wir uns alle wieder
[Musik]
es ist jede eröffnung seines restaurants
sind zürich wipkingen nach einer
mehrwöchigen kroner bedingten schließung
das hat wirklich viel stress mit den
administrationen mit dem kreditvertrag
mit der kurzarbeit mit dem personal das
nachdenklich wie die twitter mitte
bezahlen weil es gibt keine einzige
gewaltige oder besitzer fotos wo die hat
gesagt hey kommt zahlt hälfte oder zahlt
gar nichts oder zahlt müssen alle wollen
wieder mit ein gesetzlich verankerte
mieterlass für geschäftsinhaber ist zu
diesem zeitpunkt in weiter ferne
die mietkosten allez allez betriebe
betragen über hunderttausend franken
monatlich
nun fehlen dem unternehmer aus der zeit
des logins die einnahmen
[Musik]
er hat zweifel dass alle seine betriebe
überleben werden also emotionale ich
hoffe ja aber praktisch
ich glaube nicht dass glaube sonstige
geschäfte wo sehr hoch mitte dann müssen
wir ran wieder mit dem besitzer wieder
gewaltige ab machen dass die miete
reduzieren oder wir müssen einfach
abgeben
das kann man nicht leisten
[Musik]
wegen der korona krise musste company
seine finanziellen reserven anzapfen
geld welches für seinen film vorgesehen
war
mindestens 50000 franken würde er für
die fertigstellung seines low budget
projekt benötigen
also selbst wieder ich kann nicht einmal
vorstellen dass ich kann nicht um einen
film machen will und finanzierung kann
mir nicht vorstellen das wäre wäre noch
horror für mich war immer mein wunsch
mein träume die filme machen eigentlich
weitere ziele und die habe ich gedacht
jetzt habe ich erreicht da kann ich
finde wir machen auf sogar meine kosten
und jetzt werden diese finanzierungen
dann ist wirklich schwierig also und ich
will nicht in diesem gefühl erleben
[Musik]
es fehlt noch der europäische teil 1 und
das ist ein roadmovie wo ein mensch
sucht seine sohn in ganz europa das ist
die die filme
[Musik]
eine andere baustelle im leben des
unternehmers das konditorei projekt in
dietikon seit über zwei jahren steht das
lokal mittlerweile leer ohne katalog
dann wäre seit mehreren wochen in
betrieb
nun hoffen rang im saale und seine
brüder das geschäft ende sommer eröffnen
zu können
von einst ist wirklich eine belastung
dass das wäre etwas gebaut und jetzt ein
bisschen in gefahr wie die alle
geschäfte aber wenn ich sehe dann ist
dann schaffen wir ja es ist weg liefen
den ganzen heer fest zusammen
der zusammenhalt in der krise erst recht
ein rettungsanker
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit dem
ich kann mit meinem leben wieder
anstatt vier zimmer wurden die zimmer
wohnungen anstalten großen auto und
kleine auto mit es überhaupt keine
es ist ein einziges sorgen
wir sind alles auf ein schiff weißt du
ganze familie zu sorgen
ich bin mit den tausend dollar in der
schweiz gekommen
ich kann auch mit 1000 dollar den sie
zwei zwecken wie sie überhaupt kein
problem
können
[Musik]